Oh man, happy birthday, man.
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah, man. It's my birthday, too. It's
Let It's Let It's Let's Look that It's
meant to be. I'm an August 1 baby, too.
>> Oh, happy birthday, man.
>> Thank you. Thank you. But yeah, let's
let's let's get to it, man. Like, you
know, Islam versus Christianity,
>> you know, the big dog religion, which
which religion is more in continuity
with the Abrahamic prophets when it
comes to the attistation of the Quran or
the Bible, which is more reliable? I
mean, one of us is right, Mr. Avery,
right? One of us has to be right.
>> Yeah.
>> Unfortunately, somebody's wrong.
>> What you want to talk about?
>> I I like where how you started that off.
Like which one of us which which uh one
is more consistent with the you know
with the Abrahamic faith with the faith
of the prophets. I think that's a that's
a good place to start.
>> Yeah. Yeah. We we we could we could
start with that. I mean it's your it's
your panel so shoot. So, so how would
you uh trace the beliefs and creeds of
the Quran, right, to the previous
prophets? How would you trace it back?
>> Well, of course. So, we got to look back
uh when it comes to, you know, history,
right, or in contemporary evidence of
the the text, manuscripts, Quran,
hadiths, etc. So when it comes to my
theology.
>> Okay. So how do how do you know like how
would you verify that what the Quran is
saying and teaching is consistent with
what the previous prophets taught?
>> That's a great question. So in order to
verify right what the Quran is is
teaching in it of course when it's in
continuity with the previous prophets we
have to know everything about the
prophets in themselves right who did
they follow who did they speak to? What
did they practice? What did they preach?
>> Right.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, and would you agree that,
>> you know, the Abrahamic prophets
believed in one God?
>> Yeah. Yeah. They believed in one God and
they believed very specific things and
qualities about that one God. So, how
would you verify that the one God Oh, I
lost him. Either his phone died or he
lost connection. Let me try to invite
him back up. I don't know. I don't know
what happened there.
>> But Terra, how you doing? I can't hear
you. You're muted.
>> Is it better now?
>> Yeah, I can hear you.
>> Yeah. How are you doing?
>> Good.
>> It's It's I'm glad to be able to talk to
you.
>> Can I hear you? Can you hear me?
>> Yeah, I hear you now. Okay. Sometimes
when I when I pull my headphones out, it
cuts out the sound of my speaker so I
can't hear you immediately. You're a
Muslim, right?
>> Yeah, I'm trying to be a good one. Yeah,
I'm doing my best.
>> Okay. How long you been a Muslim?
>> Uh, from my birth, I suppose.
>> Okay. Okay. Cool. Cool. Cool. So the
question is do I have to try to convince
you or I can also ask questions about
Christianity?
>> Uh convince me first and then also you
can talk about Christianity.
>> So the purpose why I came at first place
like I didn't really look at the look at
the like the title of the video of your
of the sites.
>> Uhhuh. Uh so that's why I came like I
just I was just interested in you know
getting some uh opinions about Christian
about Christianity. Is it possible to do
that or
>> Yeah. So so first cuz because I do have
a theme with the live stream.
>> I would like to know why I should be a
Muslim first and um depend like let's
have that conversation first and then I
have absolutely no problem answering
your questions about Christianity.
>> Okay. So the thing is in Islam we
believe that even though that you have
you know your own uh like there are two
kind of what do you say let's say Allah
has his and there is two kind of do you
know what is
>> like let's say like decisions
>> okay
>> so like there's decisions of yours so
there's a decisions of Allah
>> so uh you cannot do anything against
that the decision of Allah That's the
whole thing.
>> But otherwise, Allah give you some like
a little bit of a choice you can have by
your own self.
>> I don't know how how much how far it
goes, but I know for sure in Islam we
believe even though that you try to
learn everything about religions, Allah
is giving you the faith. So it's not you
getting the faith by yourself, but Allah
is giving you the faith. So I will not
be able to convince you because first
Allah should be giving you giving you
the the
>> So basically what you're saying is is
that there's no reason that you can give
me to
>> I can give you many I can't give you
many
>> but but I won't. So basically you're
saying you can give me you can give me
reasons to to believe in Islam but it's
up to Allah whether I believe your
>> of course of course
>> your reasons. So, okay. What is wrong
with that?
>> Let's see. Let's Let's see if there's
any good reasons that you can give me
for being honest.
>> No, no. Like, first of all, what is
wrong with Allah deciding if you're
going to go to heaven or not?
>> I don't think there's anything wrong
with that.
>> No, no. Like you you try to mention that
as a wrong thing to have like wrong
thing happening in the Islam. So, I'm
just trying to understand
>> what is the view of God of you like what
do you think God is like? Do you think
God should be obeying some rules or you
should be obeying the
>> I did not say that. I did not say that
at all on this convers today at all.
>> Okay. Beautiful.
>> Talking about
>> So So what what are some what are some
good reasons why I should be a Muslim
>> like for example as as far as I know
what prophet brings to you is a
prophecy. Prophecy that's that's what I
that's what I know right. So there are
there are many kind of prophecy that you
can see in in in Islam whether whether
hadith or whether Quran you can you can
see many of them. So that's that's
that's complete like that's that's
explains a lot actually that's that's by
itself is enough actually.
>> I I like that. I like that prophecy is a
way for you to verify if somebody is a
true prophet or not.
>> Yeah. That's that's my way. That's how I
>> I agree with that as well. That's that's
a huge thing for me. That's the reason
why I I choose Christianity.
>> I was asking like I would like to ask
you those question but the the term are
not
>> sure.
>> Yeah. We we'll go we'll go back and
forth. So obviously if he has any false
prophecies then he's a false prophet.
Yeah.
>> Uh according to according to your view
or mine?
>> Both of ours. If he has a if he's a
false prophet if he gives a false
prophecy is he a true prophet or a false
prophet?
>> So do you mean the hadith or Quran?
Either or.
>> No, they're not either. So, do you know
the methodology between like the
difference between hadith and Quran?
>> Do you follow hadith or no?
>> Like you you you should be following
hadith otherwise you don't know how to
pray. But like there there are many kind
of uh things to look up when you
consider a hadith. You know that you
know you know.
>> So when you have an authentic hadith
>> no it's not only authentic. So like
there there could be an authentic that
many
>> brother really just really quickly
because I don't
>> I don't want to do this. I don't want to
spend time talking about what sources of
yours are authoritative or not.
>> But I told you like you're trying to
learn Islam. Like that's what I
>> No, I'm not trying to learn Islam. I
already know Islam.
>> Okay.
>> I know I know Islam. I know that you
guys have you know authentic hadith,
nonauthentic not.
>> Okay. Beautiful. But can I can I say
>> really quick please? So you follow, you
said you follow hadith. So you have
Muhammad's words, teachings, and sayings
and practices in the authentic
narrations. Correct. In the Sunna.
Correct.
>> Do I get to answer?
>> Yeah. I just want to know if that's
correct or not. Quickly, please.
>> Why do you put me in a box? I don't like
to be in a box.
>> It's It's either my brother, look, let
me tell you how this is going to go. I'm
a very simple person. I'm a very
straightforward person. I ask simple
questions that only require simple,
direct answers. I I do allow also for
you to if you're direct when you're
direct, you can also expound on your
answer, right? I'm not limiting your
words, but you have to be direct before
you start talking about other things. I
I want you to be be focused on what I'm
asking. Okay? So, if I ask something
simple like, hey, do you follow hadith?
Simply, yes, I do follow. Or, no, I
don't follow a hadith and here's why.
You know what I'm saying? Simple direct
okay so the question that I had was that
the hadith contain Muhammad's sayings
practices his teachings and sometimes
prophecies that he that he gives correct
or not correct
>> yeah that's that's what that's as long
as I go yeah
>> okay so if he gives a false prophecy
then he is a false prophet correct
>> no not really
>> so he can still be a true prophet it and
give a false prophecy.
>> No, that's not what I'm saying. So, the
reason that I came up to this like live
was, you know, like just learn about
Christianity. Even though you put me in
a in a box, I try my best. But
>> I didn't put you in that box. Islam did
that to you, bro.
>> No. Okay. Well, okay. Thank you for
that. But the thing is, I thought that
you were looking for being converted,
not just get small like simple answers.
So that's that's bring me up to the uh
like the opening statement of our of
mine. I told you even though you can
look for any kind of information,
religious information in this world, as
long as God doesn't want you to be
become Muslim, you will not. So you said
you you know Muslim Islam. I I don't
think so. I'm not going to judge you on
that. It's okay.
>> That's my statement. If you're happy
with your life.
>> Yeah. Do do you see how do you see how
you're not dealing with what I what I
asked?
>> No, I I can deal with that. But I'm not
going to just say yes or no. That's
that's not what I'm going to do. I'm
sorry.
>> Wait, just just to be clear, you mean to
tell me that you can. You said this. You
said that a good reason to be a Muslim
is because of prophecy, true prophecies
that have been fulfilled or that we can
see from the prophet. That's a reason
why people should be Muslim. That's a
good reason to be Muslim to know that
it's true. So that would mean that the
opposite is true that if he gives false
prophecies, false predictions, these
things would not be from God then and
therefore he is a false prophet. You're
telling me that you can't conce you
can't agree with that?
>> No, no, that's not what I'm saying.
>> So can you agree with that or not?
>> Why why would I be like why should I be
agreeing with that or not? Like why do
you do like why try to put people in in
a in a in a box? Why why would you do
that?
>> Do you do you do you believe that there
are there are things that are either
true or or false?
>> Well, a thing could be true or false.
There's no true
>> Exactly. So it's either or true or
false. Is a prophet a true prophet? Hold
on. Hold on. But a prophet is right.
>> Excuse me. Is a prophet a true prophet
or a false prophet? Is there a middle
ground? No,
>> as long as I know.
>> So, he's either the true prophet or he's
either a false prophet. Correct.
>> Yeah. That's that's that's that's it.
>> Give me give me a category. Give me a a
criteria of what would make a false
prophet.
>> False prophet will be someone who's
trying to fool people.
>> How? In what way?
>> Like by giving like let's say he's
making thousands of prophecies
>> and just a couple of them are true.
That's it.
>> Nice. So if he gets if he gets
prophecies wrong, then he's a false
>> You're wrong. If If the
>> I'm done. I'm done. You're wasting my
time. You're You're wasting my time.
Please don't request back up again.
You're a waste of my time, dude. What
What What a What? What is that? What are
we doing? What a waste of time. Like, do
do you do you really wake up and and and
sign up, hop on your computer and think,
"How can I embarrass myself in front of
thousands of people today?" Is that what
you guys like? Is that what motivates
y'all to move? Is that Is that how you
Is that how you like get going? How can
I embarrass myself, humiliate myself
today that in in a way that if my
parents saw this, they would be shaking
their head? If my wife or brother or
sister saw this, they'll be shaking
their head. How? What? What can I do? I
know. I'm going to hop on God Logic's
live and I'm going to waste this time.
And I'm going to make an argument that a
true prophet is one who gives true
prophecies. That's a good reason to be a
Muslim. And then I'm going to say that a
false prophet, well, really, there's no
such thing. If you give false
prophecies, that doesn't make you a
false prophet. Even though I just said
what makes you a true prophet is giving
true prophecies.
I f I
>> But you can't believe unless
>> I can't make you believe. But
>> but I faith I faith but I faith
>> I couldn't be Muslim unless
>> but I
faith
>> man don't don't come to my platform if
that's your theology if that's your
reasoning. Don't do it. Do not do it.